ladies you look great beautiful
definitely the better looking gender I
think we all agree on that like ladies
you guys are even sexy on accident like
you ever see a woman bend over is she on
her shirt for a second you're like
that's a great moment but do you ever
see a guy in short shorts something pops
out you're like ah call the police
it's a work of art like ladies you guys
look better the more skin you're showing
bikini lingerie miniskirt feel like men
we look better the more covered up we
are business suit tuxedo man in uniform
that's why I think a Female Strip Club
should be a guy coming out naked and
slowly putting clothing on yeah
you know some lady's like woo put on
that Blazer yeah by the end she's like
oh damn he's an astronaut
ladies you guys are so hot you'll touch
your own body parts in bed you're on top
like oh yeah no guy wants to touch
himself no guy's like hey all right
yeah I think you're more turned on by
men's skills ladies in our actual looks
whereas men we're all visual we go to a
strip club we're like Yeah dance on that
pole at a female strip club is more like
yeah install that pole
and you're so damn mysterious ladies we
have no idea what turns you on you know
everything that turns us on we don't
know what the hell you gals like I asked
my wife I was like what turns you on she
goes I like a man who listens I don't
know I tuned out
and then every woman's different as a
friend of mine's like what turns you on
she goes I like a man with intelligence
I'm like that's cool but how does that
work in the bedroom some guy's like ah
hypotenuse